[MUSIC]
We fully commit to that event.
The story is very much about
how do heroes move forward
from that kind of a loss.
It's a unique
circumstance because I
don't know that there was
ever a movie of that scale
and that budget where
the lead character is
lost at the end of the film.
And that's what we focus on.
We focus on surprising
ourselves, surprising
the audience, making
really dramatic choices
that we're not sure how we're
going to get out of as artists.
Killing half the
characters, and then
trying to figure out how
you move forward from there.
That is a compelling
place to put yourself in.
We don't chase bigger.
What we do chase is
great storytelling.
[MUSIC]
Whenever you're
working with IMAX
you're thinking about scale.
You're thinking
about top to bottom,
as well as side to side.
[MUSIC]
For movies like this
with cosmic settings
and larger than life characters,
there's no better way
to shoot it, and
to display it for an audience.
The epic scale of these movies
requires a canvas like that.
Even if there's a small
chance, we owe this to everyone
who is not in this room to try.
Whatever it takes.
You're dealing with a lot
of really unique voices, who
have a lot to say,
and are moving
in different tones, and
different directions,
making really different
choices from one another.
And that's exciting.
We're so close to
all of them now.
It's like family.
Robert would always host
lunch for everyone, every day,
and that's probably
my fondest memories.
It really was like summer
camp for all of us.
I like this one.
We have to expend a
lot of energy and time
making sure we keep
the information
about the movie really
controlled, and focused,
and quiet.
Because the pleasure that we
get from experiencing movies
for the first time
in the theater,
and not having
anything tipped, it's
just like we want
other audiences
to have that opportunity.
Everyone has great TVs and
sound systems at home now.
Why are they going to come
out and sit in the theater?
Well, you're going to give
them the grandest experience
that they can possibly have.
[MUSIC]
We think that people
who go see it in IMAX
are going to be blown away.
[MUSIC]